[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the show
on Google Developers Live
where we talk about common
startup problems and issues.
In today's episode, we're doing
something a little different.
We're not picking up one
particular topic, but we're
answering questions
that we've seen in
email and YouTube comments.
And I'm joined here today by
Don Dodge, startup expert,
working colleague with me here
in Google Developers--
in Developer Relations.
And we have some pretty good
questions from the viewers,
don't we, Don?
DON DODGE: Yeah, it's great.
I'm looking forward
to the questions.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, let's
see if we can get
through them all.
Some of these I actually
wonder about myself.
So this will be very
interesting for me.
DON DODGE: Hey, Martin, maybe
at this point we should
mention Root Access
to google.com.
So if people have questions,
they can send them to their
email address.
MARTIN OMANDER: Definitely.
Thanks for reminding me.
So we have the email address
rootaccess--
as one word--
@google.com.
You can send comments on the
show or questions or
suggestions for other topics.
And we read everything that
comes in, and we may put
together on a show about
the topic you suggest.
Also, as you have been doing,
please continue to leave
comments in the YouTube
comments.
We read everything.
And most of these questions
are actually from those
YouTube comments.
So one, YouTube comments,
m rootaccess@google.com,
rootaccess as one word.
All right, thanks for
reminding me.
so the very first question,
top priority.
We have no more than three
separate people asking us in
the YouTube comments about this
advisory board stuff you
talked about a couple
of episodes ago.
It sounds really good.
We should really
have advisers.
But how do you compensate
advisers for your startup?
DON DODGE: Typically you
compensate advisers with
common stock options, just
like you do employees.
So in a typical startup, there
would be a pool for employees,
and it's typically 10 to 20%
of the company is set aside
for stock options
for employees.
You take a small percentage
of that pool
and apply it to advisers.
Now, advisers typically get--
it could be 10,000 shares, and
the price will be the same as
the employee's pay at that
particular time.
It could be expressed as a
percentage of the company.
And I could typically be as
low as 1/4 of a percent
up to a full 1%.
And it depends on what they're
going to do for you.
And it depends on the stage of
the company that you're at.
So if you're just starting out,
and you need a lot of
advice on how to form the
company, how to get your
management team, how to raise
money, how to get press, if
you find someone who's going
to do all that, then the
percentage would be
closer to 1%.
Whatever percentage that you
agree on, adviser options
typically vest in two
years with no cliff.
Whereas employee options
typically vest over four years
with a one-year cliff.
The cliff means that you have to
stay a full one year before
you get the options.
And then after that,
they vest on a
quarterly or monthly basis.
With advisers, it's more common
that the options vest
over two years and that they
start vesting immediately.
So every month, they
get a 24th?
DON DODGE: Right, 1/24.
And an additional thing, you
may have heard about
acceleration, or accelerated
options, or triggers, where if
the company is acquired, the
adviser options automatically
accelerate or fully vest.
So if you do a two-year vesting
schedule with an
adviser and your company gets
acquired after eight months or
12 months or 16 months, whatever
it is, the remaining
months get fully vested and
paid to the adviser.
The reason for that is that the
acquiring company is not
going to want to keep you on
as an adviser, and you've
already given a lot of value.
Most of the value that an
adviser gives is front loaded.
So it's very early in the
process, and it sort of tapers
off as you get further out.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So what should a startup founder
do if you approach a
person you respect who's in the
community and all of that,
and that potential adviser
asks for cash?
DON DODGE: Probably decline.
Startups don't have
a lot of cash.
And the cash they do have they
need to use that to hire
people and do the things
they need to do
to build the product.
So I wouldn't spend precious
cash on an adviser.
And if an adviser is not willing
to take stock options
and sort of grow with the
company, then they're probably
not the person you want, and
they're acting more like a
consultant.
And consultants?
Sure, startups hire
consultants.
But it's for very specific tasks
that they need expertise
on, and it's for a very short
and defined period.
That's typically not what
an adviser does.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, so you want
the advisers to have skin
in the game as well, is
what you're saying?
DON DODGE: Right.
Skin in the game and to be with
you for a couple of years
to really help you build
the business.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Great.
Another thing, and this second
question, I get asked
this all the time.
When I go to hackathons, I go to
college events, people who
are straight out of college
or have a couple years
experience, they ask what
experience do I
need to start a company?
Can I start one straight
out of college?
What other jobs should I have
had before to have what it
takes to start a startup?
DON DODGE: Yeah, sure.
You can start a company right
out of college or even right
out of high school.
Mark Zuckerberg started
Facebook in college.
Larry and Sergey started
Google while
they were at Stanford.
Yahoo!
recently acquired a company from
a founder who was a high
school kid.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
DON DODGE: But those
are the unicorns.
Those a kind of rare.
Typically startups have founders
that have graduated
from college for a few years
and have done a few things.
I say actually the best
preparation for doing a
startup is to work
in a startup.
So I think after you graduate
from college or high school or
do whatever you do, go
work for a startup.
And that helps you to learn
how startups work, how you
have to raise money, how you
have to hire people, how you
get office space, how you
handle all of the
nitty gritty details.
It gives you access to investors
and to employees who
want to do startups.
Typically startups emerge
out of other companies.
So they either emerge out of--
they spin out of a startup
that failed or that grew and
they got disinterested, or
they spin out of larger
companies.
In larger companies, great
experience for a startup there
is, the closer you are to the
customer or product management
or understanding a problem,
the better off you are.
So big companies are a good
place to get experience.
But you want to be as close to
the customer and the product
requirements as you can.
So those are the two ways.
But I would say the best way,
the best preparation for
starting a company is to work in
a startup yourself, someone
else's, and learn how
it works there.
MARTIN OMANDER: My first job
was in consulting, and I
thought that was pretty nice.
Every six months I went to a
new company and saw it from
within as well.
DON DODGE: I started
the same way.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, did you?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
And you're right.
Consulting is a good way to get
a broad overview of lots
of different companies
and how they operate.
But it tends to be a short-term
kind of thing, and
you don't really get deep into
the issues that they are
solving, or the problems that
they have, for how the
dynamics with customers work,
you get an overview of it.
But there's nothing like working
in a startup and
having it in your face every day
to really impress upon you
how to handle those things.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, that makes
perfect sense, yeah.
All right, the very first show
we did back in March was about
funding and seed funding.
We got some questions
about that.
I think we may not have been
completely care about the
difference between angel
investors and friends and
family round.
Could you dig into that
a little more?
DON DODGE: Sure.
Friends and family are
just what it says.
It's people who will give you
money to start your company
because they're friends
of yours.
They know you.
They trust you, or they're
family members.
So friends and family, that's
the normal source for your
first money.
And VCs often refer to them sort
of derisively as friends,
family, and fools, because
you have to--
there's no justification,
really, for giving you that
money because you have
just an idea.
You might not have your
founding team.
You don't have a product
to look at.
You're at the very
early stages.
So only someone who
really knows you--
friends and family-- would give
you the money to do that.
And that's typically, depending
on your friends,
somewhere around $100,000.
If you have lots of friends or
rich friends, then it can go
to maybe a couple hundred
thousand dollars.
But it's a small amount of money
just to get started to
attract a co-founder and build
a demo product that you can
actually take to angel
investors, which
would be the next step.
Angel investors tend to be
retired tech executives or
entrepreneurs themselves, who
have built and sold companies
and have money to invest and
sort of like to live
vicariously through the
entrepreneurs and get involved
in a startup and
help them grow.
So they are two kind of
very different things.
The first money you get is
friends and family, and that's
probably 100,000 to 200,000.
Angel investors are the next
level, and that can be
anywhere from $250,000
to a million.
And they like to invest when
there's at least a couple of
people, so a couple co-founders,
maybe an
engineer, and that there's a
demo that they can look at
this and maybe a business plan
or some kind of plan about
where the company's
going to go.
And then once you get beyond
that stage, then you're ready
to go to VCs, Venture
Capitalists, for a series A
kind of financing.
And those tend to be a
million to 3 million.
MARTIN OMANDER: So this goes
against a little the common
wisdom and common knowledge that
friends and money, you
shouldn't mix those things.
Family and money, you shouldn't
borrow from family.
But you have to, to
get off the ground
before you have a product.
DON DODGE: Right.
You do.
And family will do that for
you when no one else will.
And I counsel people not to
take too much money from
friends and family because it's
very risky it's likely
that you'll lose it.
So you don't want to
take too much money
from any one person.
You're better off taking 5,000
or 10,000 from several friends
and family to add
up to an amount.
Don't try to take too much from
any individual because
it's very risky.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, yeah.
All right.
All right, so I also
meet teams who
found startups together.
And also most ideas usually
start with one single person,
and that single person
drives it on.
But I think you mentioned in a
show recently previously we
did that you really should have
a co-founder, and that
was something you looked
at with startups.
Why do you look at that?
DON DODGE: Well, not just me,
but investors look at that.
Y Combinator and TechStars,
everyone tends to want to have
at least two co-founders
in a company.
There are rare cases where a
single co-founder can be the
driving force and make
things happen, but
that's pretty rare.
The reasons that you want
co-founders, there are several.
One is starting a company is
really, really hard, and there
are ups and downs to this.
And when you have two people,
one can be up when the other
is down and sort of help
each other out.
Or one can be really good at
development and the other is
really good at raising money
and marketing or
that kind of thing.
Or one of the founders is a
front-end developer and the
other founder is a back-end
developer so there's balance.
It's pretty rare that one person
can do everything, and
you need co-founders that have
that same shared vision and
passion and willing to put
everything out there that an
employee might not.
So for those reasons, it's
pretty important to have
co-founders.
From an investor perspective,
having a co-founder sends a
signal that says someone else
believes in this idea enough
to quit their job and join you
to build this company.
So it's sort of validation that
someone else thinks this
is a great idea.
And so the more validation you
have from co-founders, from
early employees, or from
friends and family and
investors, that makes the next
round of investors feel more
comfortable.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So many startups build on top of
Google APIs to get started.
You don't have to build your
own payment solution.
You don't have to build your own
load balancer and things
if you run on App Engine.
You don't have to write your--
very few startups write their
own mobile operating system.
They're built on Android.
But if you do that, you're
pretty dependent on whoever
the provider is,and for these
examples, Google.
And sometimes, you
just hit a block.
You can't do what you thought
you could do with the product.
It doesn't do what you thought
the documentation says, and
you can be stuck.
What do you do then when it
comes to Google products
DON DODGE: Well, when it comes
to Google, Developer
Relations, there's a big group
of us, over 200 of us
actually, that help developers
solve problems.
We give them advice.
We give them code samples.
We solve technical problems.
So if you go to
developers.google.com, you can
find a list of the developer
advocates by product who are
there to help you.
Can go to Google Groups.
There is a group for every
Google product, a discussion
forum where you can
ask questions
and get them answered.
There are discussion forums on
Stack Overflow for every
single Google product.
You can watch Google Hangouts,
their Office Hours.
So if you go to
developers.google.com and look
for Google Developers Live,
you can see a schedule of
shows, upcoming shows, Hangouts,
and that kind of
thing where you can
ask questions.
You can go to Google I/O. There
are Google Developer
groups all over the country,
all over the world.
So there are multiple ways to
get help from Google, and
that's our job.
That's what we do.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I thought
I saw the report
recently about Google
Developer groups.
They are now in 106 countries,
I think I saw in the report.
It's pretty amazing.
But let's repeat that again--
developers.google.com to see
all the different products
there are.
And then
developers.google.com/live is
a great place to find video
about the various product
teams talking about their
products and questions they
get from the field.
DON DODGE: Right.
MARTIN OMANDER: And Google
Developer groups, I think
that's
developers.google.com/groups,
and then you can see if there's
one in your city or
your country.
DON DODGE: Right.
MARTIN OMANDER: Or start
one if there isn't one.
All right, so freemium, we
get this question a lot.
People throw around that term
a lot, and it's something
where some stuff is free and
some stuff is paid for.
But what does it really mean,
and how do you do it well
without infuriating and
nickel-and-diming your users?
DON DODGE: So freemium
is a conflated word.
It's a conjunction of free and
premium, and we say freemium.
So it means is the service
starts out free, and then you
pay a premium for additional
services, or more features, or
more bandwidth, or
more storage, or
something like that.
So freemium means that the users
can start for free and
experience the product.
And when they go over a certain
usage limit or when
they go over maybe a one-year
free trial or something like
that, then you have to pay.
I've seen hundreds of businesses
that have used the
freemium model.
And typically 3% to 5% of the
free users convert to paying
customers, and 95 to 97%
of the customers--
or users--
are actually free users.
So you need to make sure that
your business model and your
cost structure supports being
able to support these 95% of
the users that are
not going to pay.
And with software, you can
generally do that because
using things like App Engine and
free infrastructure kinds
of things allow you to support
users without actually paying
a lot of money to do that.
MARTIN OMANDER: So that
is a very good point.
I should have no delusions about
half the people wanting
to pay for coming in.
I should count on 3 to 5%.
And my business has to be
profitable at that lower
percentage.
DON DODGE: Right.
So some people do have a
misconception that half the
people will pay for
their product.
And if they will,
that's great.
You're going to do very well.
But typically, 3%
is a pretty good
conversion, and 5% is fantastic.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So quite often, I meet startups,
I'm sure you do as
well, who say that they have
this great idea, but they
don't want to talk about
it because it's
such a great idea.
They might want you to sign an
NDA or not tell you about the
idea at all.
So should startups have an NDA,
nondisclosure agreements?
DON DODGE: Yeah, nondisclosure
agreements were really an
invention of big companies, big
companies who were working
with multiple suppliers, or
consultants, or contractors,
where they had to try to
keep things secret.
But in the software world and
in the startup world,
nondisclosure agreements really
don't have a place.
For example, investors, venture
capitals, will not
sign nondisclosure agreements.
MARTIN OMANDER: Why not?
DON DODGE: For several
reasons.
The biggest one is that
they can't remember.
They talk to so many people,
they couldn't possibly
remember who they heard
something from and who not to
tell about it.
So it's just too cumbersome
a process.
it's too cumbersome of a
process, and it's too risky
from a legal point of view.
Once you've signed one of those
things, people could sue
you for some comment you made
not even knowing that it had
anything to do with what they
were talking about.
So most people will not do it.
And quite frankly, from a
startup perspective, they
don't help you much because NDAs
don't prevent bad things
from happening.
And when bad things do happen,
you still have to hire lawyers
and spend a lot of money
to try to defend or get
compensation.
So I don't think NDAs
actually work.
I don't sign them personally,
and investors don't, and I
don't see it very often.
The flip side of it is, as a
startup, you're actually
better off talking about your
idea with other people because
most people want to help you.
Most people want to understand
what you're doing and
introduce you to other people
who can help you, or give you
advice on how you can make it
work better, or sort of
broaden your horizons and
thinking about things.
So I think the benefit that you
get from telling people
your idea far outweighs any
risk, downside risk, that
someone might copy your idea.
MARTIN OMANDER: I think that's
a good point, yeah.
All right.
We also had a question
about patents.
Should startups go out, if they
have this great idea,
which most startups
think they do.
Should they go out and
get patents for that?
How much does it cost
to get one?
DON DODGE: Hm.
Good question.
Software patents are kind of
a controversial topic.
MARTIN OMANDER: Indeed.
DON DODGE: Patents in the old
days were for hardware and
mechanical processes and
things that were
manufactured, typically.
In the past four or five years,
software patents have
become kind of prevalent.
And I don't see a great deal of
value in software patents
unless you have something that
is so novel and new that you
need to protect it
with a patent.
It costs about $25,000.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, that's
significant for a startup.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
So you have to get a lawyer,
and there are fees with the
Patent Trade Office.
And all told, it's about $25,000
to get a patent.
And for complicated ones, it
can be as much as $50,000.
MARTIN OMANDER: Gosh.
DON DODGE: And beyond that, it
can take anywhere from a year
to five years to get a patent
actually issued.
So it's a long process.
It's very expensive.
And from a startup perspective,
you've either
made your startup work or fail
within a year or 18 months,
and you wouldn't have had the
patent issued anyway.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
DON DODGE: So I think larger
software companies tend to
build patent portfolios as a
defensive mechanism so that if
someone sues them for patent
infringement, they can
countersue them for infringing
on their patent.
So there's kind of a defensive
mechanism more
than anything else.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, sort
of mutually assured
destruction going on--
DON DODGE: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: --but nobody
dares to strike?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
The big companies, they use
patents as defense mechanisms
against other people
infringing them.
The reality is, if you're in
software and you're doing
anything that's reasonably
popular, you're probably
infringing on someone
else's patent.
And they don't care unless you
start to get really, really
successful and impinging
on their business.
And by that time, the idea is
that you'll have patents that
you can execute and sort of
trade and say, OK, truce.
I won't sue you.
You won't sue me.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so patents
have their place in the way
our legal system is set up and
all of that, but not for a
startup for most of
the time, you say.
DON DODGE: Unless You're doing
something really unique and
really different, it probably
doesn't make sense because of
the expense and the
time involved.
But you may want to start
thinking about patents and
start the process for later on
down the road when it could
become important.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
Yeah, time and money, those are
two things startups have
in short supply.
Better to use it to build
your product.
That's
DON DODGE: Right.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Let's see, question from the
Tony that we got on Google+.
He said that we've talked
a lot about
consumer-facing startups.
And consumer-facing
startups is--
well, the ones I've been
in have all been
consumer facing as well.
It's easy because you are
yourself a consumer so you can
sort of tell what kind
of marketing
would work for a consumer.
You can figure out how much a
product should cost because
you know how much money
you would pay for it.
But enterprise-facing startups,
that's a completely
different area.
What is different about
enterprise-facing startups?
DON DODGE: Almost everything.
MARTIN OMANDER: Almost
everything.
DON DODGE: Enterprise software
tends to be more expensive,
more complicated.
You typically have a sales
force that would sell an
enterprise software product.
It might require integration
with existing software that
the enterprise has.
It might require professional
services to help install the
software, integrate it with
other things, make it work,
customize it for the way the
customer wants to use it.
So the cost structure
is different.
The business model--
MARTIN OMANDER: That
sounds terrible.
Why would a startup ever get
into this sort of cost
structure and all this stuff
you have to set up?
DON DODGE: Well, because it's
very, very profitable.
If you get a product that people
are willing to pay for,
you can sell-- in the old days,
you could sell one seat,
a one user license for $25,000,
$50,000, and do that
in an enterprise where they're
buying hundreds of licenses.
So you could have millions and
millions of dollars of revenue
from one customer.
So it's a great business model
if you have an idea of that is
differentiated and people are
willing to pay, and it's easy
to integrate, and it's easy to
customize to the way that the
business wants to use it.
Some of the biggest software
companies in the world were
built on that model.
In the past eight or 10 years,
we have sort of moved away
from enterprise software, and
most of the investment and
most of the innovation
has been on the
consumer side on the web.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, we're
seeing consumer stuff sort of
working its way into
the enterprise
through the back door.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
So we've had eight or 10 years
of web-based development and
more recently mobile development
largely focused on
consumers, largely funded by
advertising business models or
freemium business models.
And those things work pretty
well, but the venture
capitalists and the investors
have discovered, whoa, we've
been ignoring the enterprise
for eight to 10 years.
Now there's a great
opportunity to
invest in that area.
And you're right.
What you're seeing is a lot
of social or consumer-type
features being built into
enterprise software, so making
enterprise software more
approachable and easy to use,
better user interface, mobile
access to enterprise
applications, bringing social
kinds of signals and social
inputs into enterprise
application.
So there's a huge opportunity
there.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
And then the other thing I
notice also with enterprise is
that we're all kind of
experts on consumers
because we are consumers.
But with an enterprise, you want
a pretty strong team who
knows real estate or knows
airplane leasing or whatever
you're into, right?
DON DODGE: Right, so
domain experience.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's the
word I was looking for.
DON DODGE: So having
domain experience.
Going back to that first
question you asked about what
do I need to start a company,
and I said work at a startup,
well, if you want to start an
enterprise software company,
you're better off working at a
big software company that's
done enterprise because that's
where you get the domain
experience.
And you know the features that
matter, and you know the
problems, and you know how your
customers' businesses work.
So you can identify unsolved
problems, or you can identify
efficiencies that
you can effect
with enterprise software.
So for there, you need domain
experience, and you need
experience with those
customers to
understand what they do.
So it's a completely different
approach, not only from a
business model and cost
structure and implementation
and professional services and
all that kind of thing.
Technical support
is different.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
DON DODGE: So the technical
support you provide to a
consumer is very different than
the technical support you
would supply to an enterprise
customer.
They expect more, and they
actually pay for--
MARTIN OMANDER: They're
paying for more, yeah.
DON DODGE: They pay
for support.
So it's a totally different
approach, different business
model, but very lucrative and
somewhat neglected in the past
eight or 10 years.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hm.
Sounds like a lot to
talk about there.
Maybe we should do a future
show on that.
DON DODGE: Yeah, we could
actually do a whole show just
on enterprise software and the
opportunities there, and how
you structure those companies,
and how you raise money, and
how you raise--
attract the team.
So it's a big topic.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
All right.
Thank you, Don.
I think those were all
the questions we had.
And thank you for sending
us your questions.
If you have further questions
or, for example, if we do an
enterprise-facing startups show
about that, what should
we bring up?
Or what other topics would
you like us to bring
up on future episodes?
Do either email us on
rootaccess@google.com or leave
comments in the YouTube
comments.
Thank you for watching.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]